welcome back to un censor Dr Gabel Marte
made Global headlines early this year
when he appeared in an interview with
Prince Harry the renowned trauma expert
spoke with the juk of susex about the
importance of healing in an interview to
promote Harry's Memoir well more
recently Dr Marty has been winning
plaudit for his take on the Israel Hamas
War he's an infant survivor of the
Holocaust and has been outspoken about
both the atrocities of October the 7th
and Israel's response and Dr Gabel Marte
joins me now Dr Marte thank you very
much indeed for joining me and thank you
for your patience I know you've been
sitting there listening to the interview
I just conducted uh with this poor woman
who whose parents were both kidnapped
one has been returned one hasn't yet
first of all what was your response to
to that
interview um on the human level I saw a
very decent person in evident pain in
grief um obviously deep anxiety about
the fate of her father I saw somebody
body trying to make the best um out of a
really horrific situation and my heart
goes out to
her you specialized throughout your
career in in trauma and helping people
get through trauma you've talked to many
people who've been in extreme trauma
this is a very traumatic situation these
last two months for people on both sides
for the people uh who were on the
receiving end of this massacre on
October the 7th and we've just heard
firsthand what that has been like for
the uh people in Israel who suffered
that but also of course what's going on
now in Gaza with you know many thousands
of innocent people uh being killed uh
with Israel's military response
including thousands of children um what
is your overall assessment of of where
this war is now
heading for that you need some
historical context now look I used to be
a Zionist I'm a as you mentioned I'm a
holocaust Survivor Zionist ISM was very
important for me as a Salvation of the
Jewish
people until I found out that the state
was founded based on the extration the
explosion and multiple massacres of the
local population and that's not
historically controversial so I'm taking
a long review of this and I'm saying
that the present situation cannot be
understood without looking at the
historical context and and nor can we
move forward if the present occupation
and the suppression of the Palestinians
continue so cheron your previous guest
talked about the fragile coexistence
there was no coexistance there was
oppression periodic massacres um uh land
occupation um in the West Bank The
Continuous explosion of the population
from their homes I visit visited the
occupied territories three times now the
first
time back during the first day the
appear I cried every day out for two
weeks at what I saw so this cannot go on
and I saw the news about the Elgen
marbles being returned and how you
changed your mind about that well how
about returning the land that's been
stolen from the Palestinians I'm not
talking about the state of Israel I'm
not talking about
1948 I'm talking about since 67
and what's going on right now so there's
got to be some stop to what's going on
and that's how I understand it no this
is for the sake of both Israelis and
Palestinians yes I I completely agree
with you this is a never ending cycle I
I guess from the Israelis point of view
what happened on October the 7th was on
such a gigantically horrific scale I do
get a sense that Israel is in a
collective sense of trauma and that they
are determined that Hamas should not be
allowed to perpetrate such a massacre
again and they are on record Hamas just
two weeks ago their spokesman are saying
they would do it again and again and
again if they can so that represents a
clear existential threat to the security
of people in Israel so I guess my my
question for you is what should Israel's
response be everyone is increasingly
concerned about what is going on in Gaza
clearly the loss of civilian life is on
a a catastrophic scale uh nobody thinks
this is right but at the same time I
think many would share my view that
Israel has a right to defend itself the
question is how do they do that
appropriately and how do they get rid of
Hamas if indeed you think they should
get rid of
Hamas while you're raising many
questions and many fair questions now
look I live in Canada where this country
was founded on the suppression and the
Eraser of the indigenous population and
the utter denial of their
narrative and uh in Canada for example
there the horrendous residential schools
where a few decades ago if a native
child spoke their tribal language they
have a pin stuck in their tongue now
most Canadians are not aware of that
history most Israelis are not aware of
the history of what the Palestinians
have suffered they don't know that in
1948 there were multiple massacres of
large numbers of people by Israeli
forces they don't know the history the
subjective experience of the
Palestinians and in the absence of that
knowledge October 7th would just strike
them as another horrific anti-semitic
event I understand the desire for
defense and certainly even a desire for
Revenge but that's in the absence of
knowing what the Palestinian experience
has been and the Western press and and
as in all countries where the local
population has been displaced the
majority of the population doesn't know
the history or the stive experience so
if you're asking me how to move forward
let's inform ourselves of the actual
experience of both sides not just one
side and just as you had this wonderful
Israeli woman um chaon here who spokes
with such humanity and such poignancy
you might have some Palestinians on
explaining their experience what it's
like for them to live under occupation
and in the absence of that conversation
there's no moving forward and that's all
I'm asking for I've had a number of uh
Palestinians including adop let me say
one more thing sorry yeah Israel's right
to defense yes Israel has the right to
defend itself every country does but
Israel has no right to impose an
occupation on people now look I was born
in Hungary in 1956 when I was 13
studying for B Mitzvah there was the
great Hungarian Revolution against
Soviet
occupation and uh was after that
Revolution that we became refugees and
came to Canada now did Russia have the
right to defend itself against the
Hungarian
revolutionaries you know so and and
mostly when we talk about Israel's right
of Defense we're taking isolated
Palestinian actions but we're not saying
that this population also has the right
to defend
against the occupation I'm not
justifying the the terrible events of
October the 7th I'm talking in the
absence of historical awareness it all
just looks like Israel defending itself
but against whom against the population
that has been massacring in a number of
thousands for 80 years and taking their
lands and destroying their homes and
jailing their children and torturing
them that's the history now
unless we know that it all looks like
this poor little country trying to
defend itself but against
whom against people that's been
occupying and this placing for 80 years
that's the history as Israeli historians
have shown I don't make this stuff up I
wish it wasn't true I wish I could
believe in the dream of the Jewish State
I love that dream except I found out at
what price at what nightmare that
imposed on the Palestinian
how do you see this ever getting
resolved it seems so intractable but
then as I always say so did the Northern
Ireland conflict that seemed intractable
when the IRA were committing uh Terror
atrocities but they eventually did get
to peace can you see a pathway here to
peace and what does it look
like what does it
look I can that's a great question again
look you're going to have Nick K was on
later on the tennis player I just spent
a couple of weeks in Serbia um and the
former Yugoslavia with another tennis
player Novak jokovic they have a
foundation that promotes healing and
Child Development and so on so they
asked me to speak throughout the former
Yugoslavia you know what
horrific um
um atrocities were committed there just
a few decades ago so I was in Belgrade I
was in s
I was in baluca I was in
yuana they're living together now there
are still issues to be worked out but
the minimum condition is the ending of
the occupation and the inhumane Siege of
Gaza and international law has to be
respected international law is very
clear that this occupation is illegal
that has to be the basis of any future
agreement if that was agreed on and if
Israel could live within the borders
that are internationally
recognized I believe peace is possible
now we keep talking about the hamash
charter did you know that the liud
charter the ruling party in Israel
excludes a Palestinian entity west of
the Jordan River so let's get rid of
both Charters and let's start with the
basis of recognition and peace and the
ending of this unspeakably brutal
occupation fers you have to go there to
see it for yourself as I have and you
would cry every day for two weeks as
well I'm under No Illusion about what
the Palestinian people have had to
endure and I think the the oppression of
the Palestinian people for decades has
been completely shameful and it
shouldn't have been happening I mean the
mere fact that Israel was able after
October the 7th to Simply turn off the
supplies of food and water and fuel and
so on into Gaza says it all that that is
a an occupation that is a controlling
Force controlling whether people eat or
have fuel or can heat themselves or feed
themselves um so I I you know I I I'm
under no Illusions about that I'd be
very critical of Israel before what has
complicated things for me morally with
this is that the scale of what happened
on October the 7th was so disgusting uh
and the fact that Hamas has said they
will continue to try and do the same
thing again is that I I absolutely
believe
Israel has to do what it can to remove
that threat and how you do that when
they are immersed in the civilian
population and that population is half
children uh without massive civilian
casualties on the scale we're now seeing
I don't know I genuinely don't know I
don't know how they resolve this but uh
I hope the better Minds than mine can
work a way through
this well I hope along with you as well
but again I'm saying that there's no
possibility of that until the
interational until the International
Community and particularly Israel's Big
Brothers UK and the US stop supporting
its illegal brutal inhumane and
rapacious occupation it can't happen
without some pressure um and again most
Israelis are simply not aware I've been
to Israel talked to people they have no
idea what's happening a few miles away
from when they're sitting in Tel Aviv
having coffee and they have no idea or
in Jerusalem and they have no idea
what's happening a few miles away how
those people under occupation are living
and this has been do it's not that
they're not capable of being aware but
like most people they just not and I'm
saying that unless we fully get the
palestin experience
historically and throughout the decades
and into the present moment we can't
possibly understand what's going on here
now in 2005 there was a a study appeared
in the Journal of world Psychiatry
looking at
traumatized populations under War
conditions the most traumatized children
in 2005 this is before Hamas gained
power in uh in Palestine and in Gaza the
most traumatized kids were in
Gaza this population has been
traumatized
severely of course they're full of Rage
I'm not justifying anything they did but
I'm saying what do we expect from this
population that's been suppressed and
tormented and crucified for decades
sorry we're going to have a short break
and come back I'll come back with after
the break welcome back to on sensor Dr
Gabel Marte still with me Dr Marte I
want to talk to you about something else
now which made you of globally uh
brought to the world's attention early
this year when you sat down with Prince
Harry to talk about his book spare and
it got a lot of attention this I just
wondered you've expressed since then
regret really that you ever did it uh
why do you feel that
way I express regret not about the uh
having done the interview but the way I
agreed that it would be um conducted
what I mean by that is I had a strong
sense that this should inter you should
be free for everybody it should be a
service to the public it was a great
discussion I really enjoyed meeting
Harry I found him to be humble and
sincere and genuinely interested in
promoting mental health and looking at
the trauma that underlies people's
mental health issues what was wrong with
it is that was put behind a pay wall so
a lot of people people had to buy his
book in order to watch the interview a
lot of four million people already had
they were excluded from watching the
interview and so that's what I regretted
I did not regret doing interview I
enjoyed it and I thought it was a really
good discussion between two people to
flawed people who were willing to look
at their flaws so I um I'm glad I did it
but in that respect I would not agree to
it unless it was aired freely for the
whole world to see Harry felt the same
way by the way afterwards we both wanted
it released but the lawyer said that
since it was Market as a pay for viewing
onetime event would' be slapped with a
clash acction suit if we released it so
unfortunately a lot of people didn't see
it those who did for the most part a lot
of appreciation let me let me play a
clip from the interview you conducted
I'll come back to you after this and
then at some point you say towards the
end of the
book when is someone in his family going
to break free and live M have you done
that I have
now yeah um what does it feel like feels
great I do I you once the book came out
I felt I felt incredibly free I felt a
huge weight off my
shoulders now we have very different
views about Prince Harry I'll laid my
cards on the table I I think he's
behaved disgracefully towards his family
particularly when Prince Philip was
dying then the queen was dying the
family was in grief and all he and his
wife Megan seemed to have done to me is
Chu Flames at the family from abroad and
tried to damage them and the institution
of the monarchy but it's interesting
that he believed there and I recognize
you feel differently he believed there
that he's found freedom but in all your
experience of talking to people through
you know similar kind of family trauma
if you like can you really find
happiness if your freedom involves
disconnecting yourself from your entire
family well it's a really good question
my eldest son and I Daniel with whom I
wrote our book The Myth of normal trauma
illness and healing in a toxic culture
are writing a new book now it's called
hello again a fresh start for parents
and their adult children families are
tough families hurt each other children
are traumatized in families Harry was
traumatized in his family not because
his parents didn't love him but because
they were car in their own trauma and
pass it on to the next Generation I
passed on my trauma to my children I
didn't mean to but I did and so
sometimes people can work these things
out if there's the willingness on both
sides and people do make mistakes and I
do believe Harry made some
mistakes um that goes both ways um
people can work it out and sometimes
they can't and sometimes people find
Freedom and having to disconnect in in
the book The myid the normal I talk
about this tension that we all have
between authentic and belonging
attachment and authenticity if we can
belong and connect and be our true
selves that's ideal but what do we do if
in order to be our true selves our
families or our communities won't accept
us well for example over this Israel
issue I made a decision a long time ago
that for me speaking the truth which
doesn't make me right but speaking my
truth is more important than who likes
me and who doesn't like me in
1967 I wrote an article after the war
arguing by that time that Israel had
occupied this territories quite
deliberately and then never give them
back my father kicked me out of the
house I accepted that now my father
later on came around and actually agreed
with me but I made a decision that to be
myself and to speak my truth I'm willing
to break the contact if that's what it
took a lot of people in that situation
and and Harry in that family with a very
troubled young mother and a Loveless
marriage and a father was having an
affair before he was born a family that
was not a whole lot of taching and
holding there's multiple reasons to say
that he was a very traumatized child and
in order to become himself he had to
distance himself now did he do it right
exactly the ideal way maybe not but you
know what when I look at myself at age
38 or 35 boy did I make a lot of
mistakes so this is all part of the
human drama yeah and families sometimes
work it out sometimes they don't it's
true it's very true Dr Marty I've got to
leave it there it's been fascinating
please come back on the show again
another time I've really enjoyed talking
to
you likewise I really appreciate you
giving me this uh this listening thank
you a pleasure thank you very
much